皆様に
ズズッ!(鼻をすする)
謝らなければいけないことがあります
スーン、ズン゛(鼻をすする)
う、うっ(泣)
昔、Twitterで
ズズッ!(鼻をすする)
卒業…、うっ!
論文の
研究テーマが
っスン(鼻をすする)
じゃんけんで(泣)
確実に勝つ方法って言ったんですけどぉ…(泣)
おおおおぉぉぉお
嘘でしたああぁぁあ!!!(泣)
あぁぁぁあーー!!(泣)
ああ゛ーっはーーーーーーー!!!!!(泣)
えぇ゛ーーーん、え゛んえ゛んえ゛んえ゛んえ゛んえ゛んえ゛んえ゛んえ゛ん!!(泣)
わんわんわんわんわんわん!!(泣)
嘘ついてすいませんでしたっ!(泣)
っスン!　はっ…、ズズッ!(鼻をすする)
僕も言いたくなかったんですよ!(泣)
僕も言いたくなかった…(泣)
ズズッ!(鼻をすする)
はっ…、うぅ…(泣)
卒業論文を、印刷してるときー(泣)
じゃんけんについて書いたって言ったら面白いんじゃないかなと思って(泣)
ううぅ゛ぅ゛ぅ゛ぅぅぅ゛ぅ゛う゛う゛!!!!
ふざけてTwitterで言ったらー(泣)
っうぅ(泣)
なんかみんな信じちゃって!!(泣)
ははあぁぁぁぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛!!!!!
なんか…、みんな…、すごい…、リツイートとかされてぇ(泣)
あぁぁぁぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛あ゛あ゛!!!!
なんかじゃんけん研究会とかから連絡も来て(泣)
言うに、言うに、言うに言えなくなってしまったんですよ(泣)
お゛ええ゛ぇ゛ぇ゛ぇ゛え゛え゛!!!!!
ウッッ…、すいませんでした(泣)
普通の人なら…(泣)
うぅっ!
信じないと思っ…(泣)
っへぇぅ!
てぇ、嘘ついたんですけど…(泣)
じゃんけんについては書いていません(泣)
じゃんけんに確実に勝つ方法ないです!!!(泣)
あぁぁぁぁ゛ぁ゛ぁ゛あ゛あ゛!!!!
はい、というわけで、卒業論文はじゃんけんではないことをちゃんと書いてました
はじめしゃちょーです。
今日をもちまして
卒業論文の最終発表会が終わりましてー
やっと、卒業論文に関することはすべて!!
終了でございます!!
長かったよぉ…
ほんとに長かった!
どんぐらいかなー、もう去年ぐらいかなー
もう去年ぐらいからの動画でずっとなんか、卒業論文書かなきゃとかね
卒業論文しなきゃとかどうこう言いながら動画を撮ってて
今年のお正月も、実家に帰る暇もなく
家で引きこもってずっと卒論書いてー
なんとか期限に間に合い
けどその合間を縫ってー
YouTubeの動画を作ったり
東京に行ったりでー
もうハチャメチャすぎてー
多分なんですけど、人生でこんなに忙しい期間はなかったなと思ってます
ぃや、苦しかった!
正直言うけど苦しかったです
それでも何とか頑張ってねー
何とか無理やり時間を作って
毎日動画を出そうと思って頑張って…んですけど
卒業論文は一通り終わりました!
レポート用紙、多分20…何枚くらいかな?
けっこう書いたんですけどー
大学生はね、大変ですよ!!
まー、内容はどうこうにしろねー、なんとか一応そのー
提出もできてちゃんと終わったので!
動画でずっと卒論、卒論って言ってたから
これは、ちゃんと言わなきゃと思って今回動画を撮っております!
本当に長い期間でしたが…
なんかいろいろ、すごいねぇ!
卒論頑張ってとか、学校頑張ってとか言われてー
嬉しかったんですよ…
ほんとに、応援して下さった皆さま、ありがとうございました!
無事!　はじめしゃちょー、卒業に1歩近づくことができました
来週のテストさえ、ちゃんとクリアできれば!　卒業なので
もう少しです!
最後の学生生活、頑張ろうと思います!
ほんっとに時間に追われてた…
なんかあんまりね～、こんな忙しいとか言うとちょっとカッコ悪いなーと思ってて
あんまり言いたくないんですけどー
正直、めちゃくちゃ、時間がなかったです
もう何度!　1日が24時間以上あってほしいと願ったことか!
てくらいね!　もうほんとに寝る時間もなくて
ご飯食べる時間もなかった時もあってー
動画を休めば何とかなったかもしんないんですけどー
それも自分の中ではしたくなくて
なんとかかんとかやってきて、ここまでこれました
ほんとに、こんな忙しい中でー
卒業論文が書けたのはマジで!　皆さまの、おかげでございます
もう少し!　大学生活、頑張っていこうと思います!
あっ!　このまま終わらないよ!?
このまま終わったらなんか訳の分からない動画になるんでー
はい!
2月の質問コーナーのコメントを!
ここで募集しようと思いまーす!
テスト後には出すから!!
はい、という訳でこの動画のコメント欄にー
僕に対する!　もはや質問ではありません
も、質問でもいいしー
リクエスト、言いたいこと
文句!
プロポーズ!!
罵倒!!!
もうなんでも好きなことを書いてください!
その書かれたコメントからー、僕が適当にピックアップして
質問コーナーの動画を!　作ろうと思います!
も、多分質問コーナーの動画作ってる頃には僕多分もう
あれなんで!
テスト終わってるんで!
も、多分晴れ晴れとした気持ちで多分もう、動画撮ってると思います
お楽しみに!
2月の中旬…ぐらいに、質問コーナー動画を出そうと思います
も、適当にパパっとしていつの間にか出すんで
皆、気楽に待っててください
質問コーナーのコメント、書いてくださいという動画でした!!
という訳で、ちょっとテスト勉強をもう少し、頑張ろうと思います!
じゃあな!!